Congratulations, SCP Explained fans - you've
just scored yourselves front row seats to
the freak show.
Hey, don't be so nervous - I know clowns don't
necessarily have the best rep these days - thank
you very much, John Wayne Gacy and Stephen
King - but I guarantee you I'm not like the
other clowns at Herman Fuller's Circus of
the Disquieting, I'm as human as you are.
Well, okay, that's potentially debatable,
depending on how stingy you are with your
definitions of what exactly counts, but we'll
get into that later.
See, I'm what they call an anomalous humanoid,
known to the eggheads who work for Miss Essie
P. Foundation as SCP-2094, object class Euclid,
whatever the heck that means.
My friends call me Barney, on account of the
fact that's my government name, but if you're
a fan of the Circus you probably know me better
by my stage name: Motormouth.
Pretty fitting nickname, ain’t it?
I tried to make “Barney the Bottomless”
happen in the early days of my career, but
it wasn't catchy enough to stick.
Then one day my buddy Quincy threatened to
barf a swarm of bees on my face if I didn't
shut my motormouth, and that's been my stage
name ever since.
Now that we're properly introduced, you're
probably wondering what cool tricks I have
up my sleeve to get me that nifty Essie P.
designation.
Well, it's not because of my heightened manual
dexterity, my juggling skills, my accordion
playing prowess, or even my nearly perfect
impression of Jane Fonda as Barbarella - so
if you guessed any of those, you're way off
base.
See, I'm the subject of a quote-unquote “spatial
anomaly”, accessible through my mouth and
throat.
In plain English, I've got a second stomach
- anything I swallow disappears into a pocket
dimension made of anomalously elastic intestinal
tissue, where it's stored until I need it
again.
If there's a limit to how much I can store
in there, I haven't found it yet.
The amount of stuff in there has no effect
on my overall weight or my ability to move,
once it's in there it's just kinda gone until
I want it back.
On top of that, my lower jaw can be stretched
up to 6 feet – that's 2 meters for those
of you weirdos who use the metric system - in
any direction.
So in addition to being a juggler and a clown,
I also made a killing as a geek at Herman
Fuller's Circus.
I don't mean geek as in “owns a signed James
T Kirk funko pop that's still in mint condition”,
I mean in the sense of somebody who gets paid
to eat weird junk as a form of performance,
although I have been accused by some of being
both.
Now you're probably thinking, “Motormouth,
my pal, my good buddy, there's so many careers
you could've gone into with that very specific
set of skills.
Garbage disposal, one-man moving van service,
left luggage attendant at grand central station,
sky's the limit, man!”
Well, sure, but I love the circus!
They're the only family I've got in this world.
I came to them when I was just a wide-eyed
punk kid of eight years old, and they took
me in like I was their own flesh and blood.
Yes, believe it or not, I wasn't actually
born into the circus life.
A lot of circus and performing arts folk are
born into the industry - 'born in a costume
trunk' as they say - but unfortunately, that's
not me.
I was born in New York City on April 10th,
1976.
My dad had took off long before I showed up,
leaving me in the care of my dear old mom.
My special abilities manifested early and
my mom recognized them right away.
You know how little kids are always putting
things in their mouths, right?
It's cute when it's a block or an action figure,
but less so when it's the entire coffee table.
Yeah, my mom was fully aware of what I could
do, and she hated my guts for it.
Not only had her baby daddy flown the coop,
but the kid she was raising was a freak of
nature who she could barely stand to look
at.
And trust me, the feelings of resentment were
totally mutual.
One of my favorite pastimes as a youngster
was to go out and find me as many small animals
as I could get my little hands on, then go
back inside while mom was laid out on the
parlor chair sleeping off one of her special
grown-up headaches she got from downing a
bottle and a half of her special grown-up
juice.
I'd make like I was gonna innocently ask her
a question, smiling one of those adorable
little 8-year-old smiles, then instead of
saying anything I'd just barf up a couple
dozen rats onto her lap.
Despite how much I hated living at home, it
never occurred to me that I could leave.
I was a pretty wide-eyed kid.
Mom kept me isolated from the wider world,
I guess outta fear that I'd eat somebody.
But one night, as I was going to bed, I met
Manny.
Who's Manny?
Come on, if you know anything about the Circus
of the Disquieting, you know Manny.
Don’t you guys already have a video on that?
Manny’s short for “the Man With the Upside
Down Face.”
He was Herman Fuller's right hand, in charge
of a lot of the backstage stuff, including,
shall we say, “talent acquisition.”
Who knows how he figured out where I was or
that I could do what I could do, but just
like magic, he showed up at my window.
Should I have been worried that a man with
an upside-down face was at my window?
Probably.
But I guess I was just happy to see someone
who was more of a freak than me!
Manny offered me a place in a real family,
where I wouldn't be cooped up.
He said freaks belonged out in the world,
sharing their talents, making people laugh
and cry and puke all over the place.
I didn't even hesitate, I took him up on his
offer.
Mommy dearest was so deep in the drink that
she didn't notice I left.
And that was that!
From that day forward I was a member of Herman
Fuller's family.
I never looked back, not even once.
Now, it may also surprise you to know that
I wasn't always the picture of confidence
I am today.
My first job with the circus was as the human
clown car.
As a kid I didn't have a lot of stage presence,
and I didn't talk much, so the natural thing
to do was to send me out to the ring and let
the clown troupe come marching outta my mouth,
to the surprise and delight of the audience.
I learned juggling from a guy named Scythe.
He was a human pin cushion, but like most
of us at Herman's, his abilities were way
beyond what you'd see at any common or garden
circus.
Scythe was incredible at what he did, you
could stick a shiv in every square inch of
this guy and he'd never bat an eye!
Total jerk, though, and awful with kids, so
how he got the job of training me in the ways
of the juggler is totally beyond me.
If I so much as talked out of turn, he'd bean
me in the head with a juggling pin.
Not hard, just enough to hurt.
I know that sounds bad, but at least it toughened
me up.
I think Scythe was just jealous of me in hindsight
- I was a natural and I think he saw me as
a threat.
Scythe eventually died in a fire stunt gone
wrong.
They held a funeral for him, but I was busy
that day.
Clowning I learned from a guy called Scruffy
McGrubbins.
Good ol' Scruffy.
He had all the grace and countenance of a
chain-smoking grizzly bear, and he was worth
more to me than all the grandmothers I never
had.
He never talked to me like I was stupid, the
way most people talk to kids.
Scruffy took me seriously, and he imparted
unto me all the knowledge he'd picked up in
his years in the circus trade.
He was a very wise man as clowns go.
He never minced words, never messed around
with small talk, he just jumped straight into
a conversation and expected you to catch up.
I never knew what happened to that guy.
I've heard he quit the clown biz and settled
down in a nice apartment in Kent.
I hope he's having a good day, wherever he
is.
So I did the juggling thing for a while - tossing
around balls and pins and other junk and catching
it in my mouth.
Sometimes I'd put a plant in the audience,
call them up and swallow them whole as part
of the act.
Eventually, I started working on a double
act with another freak by the name of Theo.
See, Theo could flip himself inside-out, but
he was also a pretty skilled acrobat, so he'd
do a high dive jump over the audience, pull
his insides outside, then aim himself down
my gullet.
It was a pretty great act if I do say so myself.
Theo and I even dated for a while - what can
I say, I find guys just as fun to swallow
as gals.
But after he and I broke it off, I decided
I needed to change up my act.
That's when it hit me: Motormouth.
Picture this - here's me, an assistant on
either side ready to pull my mouth open.
Then a Chrysler comes barreling into the big
top, hits a ramp, and drives right through
my mouth into my second stomach.
It was a dangerous act - I'm magic, sure,
but not immune to being run over - but it
was the best act I ever came up with.
Oh, I could tell you some stories about my
time with the circus.
There was the time my tapeworm started talking
to me, the time I was involved in overthrowing
Herman Fuller himself and installing Icky
as our new ringmaster, the time I hooked up
with one of the non-human
Capital-C Clowns...though
this is a family-friendly channel, so maybe
not that one.
That's not what you wanna hear, though, is
it?
You'd rather hear about how I got myself captured
and locked up by Miss Essie P. Foundation.
Alright, why not.
I've already spilled the rest of my backstory.
So, Manny - you remember Manny, from earlier,
right?
- He saved a lot of kids like me, and when
he did he usually put me in charge of teaching
them how to perform.
But there was this one girl he brought in
who broke down crying in the middle of one
of our juggling lessons.
She said she wanted to go home.
And that's when I knew that Manny had graduated
from saving runaways and abused kids like
me to abducting kids with powers.
Of course, I confronted him about it - I told
him point-blank, that's not how we do things
anymore.
Herman hadn't been around for years at that
point.
We were better than that.
He gave me some garbage about him doing what
he had to to keep the circus alive.
Can you believe that?
Even with everything we were doing, he still
thought the circus was on the verge of collapse.
So I took the girl home.
I stored her in my gut and snuck her onto
the Kaleidoscope - That's the machine we use
to move all the parts of the circus from place
to place.
The kid was back with her parents before dinner,
but when I returned to the circus, Manny was
furious.
In hindsight, I think it nearly killed him
to do it, but he said he had to make an example
of me.
So he threw me in a box, locked with chains
and painted with the words 'For Essie' on
the top.
I was left out in a field in Kamifurano, Japan,
like a wrapped present for Miss Essie P. And
that's how I ended up in containment.
Truth be told, I've slept in prisons more
comfortable than this place - the beds are
hard, the food is gross, and the little red
light on the security camera keeps me up at
night.
Not ideal conditions for a circus superstar
of my caliber, but, as my
old pal Gourdi Lanternskull
used to say, it's the performer that makes
the stage.
Now go check out “Trapped in a Game - SCP-1733
- Season Opener” and “SCP-426 - I am a
Toaster” for more of the downright weirdest
anomalies out there!